devil prose yen et des villes prose y un
curieux de connaître le futur visage du
quartier central de leur ville pour
cette première concertation publique
l'espace michel petrucciani a fait le
plein la mairie a souhaité associer les
habitants pour l'aménagement du secteur
du trianon et de ses alentours
consultez le public les habitants de
comprendre leurs préoccupations par
rapport à ce qui va être indiqués c'est
toujours intéressant de le faire de vive
voix quoi nous sommes nombreux est venu
ce soir donc nous sommes tous pour la
plupart très concernés ce projet fait
suite à l'élaboration du nouveau pel
hull plan local d'urbanisme
objectif de cette première réunion
définir la méthode de concertation
proposée aux villes provient durant les
douze prochains mois en fait ville
procès construit à des époques
successives comme beaucoup de villes
parlent par l'apport de nouveaux
quartiers c'est un quartier qui est au
croisement de tous ces quartiers et qui
doit nous permettre de
de créer du lien entre ces différentes
époques de construction de villepreux et
surtout d'améliorer le fonctionnement
global de la ville
si pour l'instant aucune piste sur les
aménagements prévus n'a été lancé
d'autres réunions et ateliers sont
prévus
prochain rendez vous le 10 février sur
la place du marché pour une balade
urbaine
les habitants peuvent également donner
leur avis par mail ou en mairie